it's a company or a country is in  Decline you can try Voice or you can try  exit voice is basically changing the  system from within  um whereas exit is leaving to create a  new system in 2013 the serial  entrepreneur biology srinivasan gave up  widely discussed talk at the tech  incubator y combinator on a paradigm  derived from the work of The Economist  Albert o hirschman there are two paths  to reform he explained to speak up and  remake a system from within or to leave  and build something new that might one  day take its place in his new book the  network State sreenivasan makes the case  for exiting today's nation states as  they exist and migrating much of our  Lives onto the internet ever improving  digital tools give humans an  unprecedented ability to create opt-in  fully voluntary communities where people  choose to meet work live and love